it's like a big world with animals for
our nice there's ice cream clouds and
Wow hello nice to meet you what's your
name
Coco we're gonna see what you think the
future should look like and then later
on created in a virtual reality does
that sound good
what when you close your eyes do you
imagine a happy place that you were
going to go to to be able to get to
sleep what's it look like it's like a
big one with animals who are nice what
kind of animals are they a cheetah what
is in the sky in this land
I see clouds and rainbows if you're
standing your happy place are you in a
building I have some rainbow house now
do you have pets of this house
maybe you could edit 108 okay
are there bridges are the streams lots
of bridges
even the carpark there's a cop okay in
the future this dices will drive the
cars by their self if you could invent
one thing hasn't existed before what
would it be a robot what does it do does
it does it pick the marshmallows yeah
and it has lots of lugs are you excited
I am going to make your a magical happy
place a reality and you'll be able to
see it very soon how's that sound
yep awesome high five in the meadow high
five high five no all right leave me
hanging them alright hello welcome back
open your eyes for me okay
[Music]
my house
[Music]
there's a collapse in the car
[Music]
it has not
[Music]
sir Claude state school to be at least
100 thing
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I will say hey papa welcome back it's
reality good high five
you